why you
L and you
CH and you try to make full L of
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
so Wendel vaugh first appears in Captain
America volume 1 issue number 217 in
January of 1977 now one important or I
guess two important distinctions that we
need to make over the course of this
comic book is that wle vaugh will first
be introduced to us as Marvel boy but
it's important that we understand that
he is not the first Marvel boy
eventually his name will transition and
he will become quazar but the first
Marvel boy was Robert Grayson and he
appeared as Marvel boy issues number one
and two in 1950 and then later on an
astonishing Marvel boy for issues uh 3 4
5 7 and six at which point his series
was cancelled but what we also need to
clarify here is that the quantum bands
don't appear here for the very first
time the quantum bands actually appeared
during the stories of Marvel boy in the
1950s and that that version of the
Marvel boy didn't nearly have the kind
of power that wend Von will demonstrate
with the quantum bands as he gains the
quantum bands in his solo series with
his uh with the origins and when we see
him in this comic as well as some of the
comics that came along later on but the
other thing to bear in mind here again
as a little bit of an introduction is
that much like the Silver Surfer what
we'll see here is that Wendel Von will
first be introduced to us and he already
has his powers it won't be until we get
into a solo series that we will learn
the origin by behind how he gained his
abilities as well as what it is that the
quantum bands were created for and what
his role will be within the Marvel the
Marvel universe so what we see starting
out with uh Captain America issue number
217 is that the Falcon and Captain
America are signing autographs for a lot
of younger kids and again this is
something that you saw pretty common
pretty frequently in comic books in the
1960s this was simply just a way for uh
Marvel Comics to demonstrate to the
reader that they were teenage friendly
and a child-friendly source of
entertainment but what we see is that
the Falcon begins to pull Captain
America off and tell Captain America
that the two of them need to get back to
their meeting and this is done for a
couple reasons the first reason is
because they're sort of overwhelmed by
the number of kids teenagers that want
autographs but two there was a previous
set of events that took place whereby
Captain America's mind is sort of at a
different place now we're not
necessarily going to go into this just
because it's not very relevant to the
idea of wle vaugh and how he becomes
quazar we're simply just stating this so
that you guys understand why it is that
Captain America isn't really the one to
say that we need to get on with our
mission so what we see is that Captain
America and the Falcon head to a barber
shop and when they head to a barber shop
we see that both Barbers remove the
current customers from the premises and
they allow Captain America and the
Falcon to sit in the barber's chairs
from here we see that as Captain America
and the Falcon are sitting in the chairs
that they were lowered down below the
building and of course we see that one
of the previous customers returns and
the the barbers in particular tell the
customer they're ready to go ahead and
take care of him now from here we
transition back to Captain America and
the Falcon and we see that what they've
done here is they've lowered down into
one of many Shield complexes this is
simply just a shield complex that exists
below this barber shop there are multi a
multitude of Shield complexes that exist
in this same facet that is to say they
exist beneath or are part of very
inconspicuous locations but then that
what we see going on here is that a few
sh Shield soldiers jump out and Ambush
Captain America and the Falcon and of
course we see that for the most part
Captain America and Falcon are easily
able to overpower these Shield agents
they're really not much of a challenge
for the fighting prowess of either of
these individuals what we also see here
is that Nick Fury and dum dum Dugan
appear and uh they call off the shield
agents and what we learn here is that
they had gained information which had
indicated that Captain America had
intended to uh turn against um Shield
that Captain America was a traitor and
of course Captain America is not really
sure where they're getting this
information from but the whole reason
why the shield agents had attacked
Captain America and Falcon was for Nick
Fury to analyze them in terms of their
fighting abilities and to determine
whether or not they were actually
Captain America and the Falcon which of
course Nick Fury was able to determine
what we see is that Nick Fury takes
Captain America and the Falon to where
they're holding the prisoner that has
supposedly given them given them this
information and what we see is that this
prisoner's mind is being examined by
shield and that this prisoner has for in
some way or another had false memories
implanted into his mind which when his
mind was red had informed Shield that
Captain America intended to turn against
him now of course as we said Captain
America has been revealed by Nick Fury
to be the genuine article he's not he
really has no intention to uh to
infiltrate or to I'm sorry to betray
Shield but Nick Fury's concern here is
that this won't just stop a Captain
America that there may be others who
have infiltrated shield and Nick Fury's
mission is to to uh to find these
individuals to locate who they are and
to weed them out from here we see that
this prisoner is taken away but as the
prisoner is being taken away he reaches
in his eye for something or another and
what we learn is that what he's done is
he's taken a pill taken some kind of a
dropper and this result results in him
dying now why it is that he did this is
something that we don't really know and
in truth it's not extremely important
but I would go as far as to say that
this is probably a mantra among the
corporation which is the organization
looking to um I guess uh infiltrate
shield and that the mindset of the
corporation's agents is that if you're
ever caught in the process or over the
course of your duties to simply just
kill yourself of course we see that uh
without this in without this individual
as a means for them to interrogate
people even more that for the most part
um Shield is really not sure where to go
here that they're really sort of left
hanging in terms of uh possible
information that can be gained what we
also see is that Nick Fury has created a
sort of superpowered team and that the
purpose of this team is to uh be a group
of individuals that will fight on behalf
of shield now the goal of Nick Fury is
to have Captain America train and Lead
this group now this is when we're first
introduced to Wendel vaugh as C or sorry
as a Marvel boy or quazar and what we
see here is that the first member of the
team is the Blue Streak the second
member of the team is the vamp the third
member of the team is an individual
named the Texas twister and the last
member of the team is Marvel boy himself
Wendel vaugh now this is when things get
a little confusing to the average reader
it's not until Marvel 2 And1 issue
number 53 that Wendel vaugh will start
being referred to as quazar but we see
that W vaugh mentioned here that they
may recognize him and that perhaps they
might recognize him from the 1950s
version of himself now this is simply
just Wendel vaugh pointing to the idea
that at one point in time there was a
version of Marvel Marvel boy with which
he looks almost exactly identical to but
he is a totally separate individual we
also see him demonstrate his powers and
say that his powers are almost identical
to Marvel Boy's powers from the 1950s
although windel Von is able to
demonstrate a little more uh destruction
in terms of his capabilities of course
we see Windon say that these powers are
courtesy of Tony Stark which again is
something that we'll get into when we
get into the origin story of windel
vaugh what we see here is that Captain
America refuses to lead this team
Captain America tells Nick Fury that he
does not want to be part of this that he
doesn't want to effectively babysit a
bunch of new people from here we see
that uh as a result of Captain America
refusing to uh train Nick Fury's team
that Nick Fury orders the team to attack
Captain America from here we see Captain
America tell the Falcon to hold off and
Captain America is able to
single-handedly defeat all of the
members of Nick Fury's new team from
here as the fight progresses we see that
Captain America calls off the conflict
and all this really was was a chance for
Captain America to examine the team a
chance for Captain America to see what
it was that they're capable of we see
that Captain America says that of course
that these individuals were provoked and
that this was simply a test and he just
wanted to see how good they were he said
that they're pretty good in terms of
their individual fighting but that their
ability to fight as a team to fight as a
cohesive unit is something that just
isn't there and that they're going to
need to practice fighting as a team in
order for them to be successful as a
team and so what we see is uh Captain
America is saying that the Falcon that
Sam Wilson is the best person to lead
this team Sam Wilson as far as Captain
America is concerned has gone as far as
he can go in the sense that Sam Wilson
has learned most everything he can learn
from Captain America that Sam Wilson and
lot of ways in terms of uh his mindset
in terms of his understanding of combat
of how to train groups how to fight
against groups and so on that he's on
par with Captain America the only thing
he lacks in relation to Captain America
is Captain America's physical abilities
from here we see that Sam Wilson is a
little shocked Sam Wilson's a little
surprised and he's a little taken aback
by the fact that Captain America so
willingly offered to appoint him as the
leader of this team and of course we see
that as Captain America goes about his
business that uh the Falcon along with
Nick Fury be I guess undergo the process
of training these individuals to fight
cohesively as a unit now there is a
little bit more to this comic involving
Captain America himself but again this
is just a discussion about quazar or
about Wendel vaugh and so what we're
going to do is we're going to transition
to quazar number one now we could stop
and we could talk about Marvel 2 and one
but for the most part Marvel 2 and one
like several other comic books that uh
wvon made appearances in really doesn't
do anything for us other than establish
the fact that Wendel
vongh uh for went by the name quazar
that he was introduced to us with the
name quazar and that's really all it
does it's the first time that we will
ever see wlon um arrive as quazar or I
guess be mentioned or or discussed as
quazar so with quazar issue number one
we get the actual origin story of Wendel
vaugh we learn what it is that had
happened what it is that had taken place
with regards to both um Robert Grayson
as Marvel boy and Wendel vaugh in terms
of his gaining his abilities now with
Marvel boy it's not necessarily as deep
of a backstory as we will get with
quazar issue number two in terms of the
story being told from the um the
perspective of death urge which of
course is a villain that we'll discuss
slightly during this comic but what we
see here is that it's some point along
the line prior to the Fantastic 4 that
Robert Grayson had the abilities of
quazar he had the quantum bands and that
due to some set of circumstances that we
didn't really know anything about that
he had turned against uh Humanity he had
become a villain instead of a a
superhero and that as a result he had
confronted the Fantastic Four now there
was about a 10year gap or so between the
time that he had first showed up and the
time that he had reappeared as a bad guy
but nonetheless what we learn is that
during this uh conflict with the
Fantastic 4 he is I guess more or less
um overwhelmed by the power of the
quantum bands and is totally incinerated
from here we switch to the perspective
of Tony Stark and we see that Tony Stark
is I'm sorry we switched to the
perspective of Nick Fury and we see that
Nick Fury is talking to Tony Stark among
others about the uh the quantum bands
themselves and about how the quantum
bands are uh for the most part something
they're totally unaware of they're not
exactly sure how to analyze them or what
they're capable of and so Tony Stark is
turning this over to the science
division of Stark Industries from here
what we also learn is that Wendel Von's
father is a uh is a member of this
particular science Community his name is
Gilbert vaugh and for the most part he's
not an extremely important character
during these origin stories but he's
important enough in the sense that he
plays a pretty important role in terms
of how Wendel vaugh perceives himself
and how it is that uh he functions
throughout his normal life and and why
it is that he gets involved in the
things that he does but what we see is
that wend vaugh I'm sorry that uh
Gilbert vaugh will be the head scientist
undertaking the task of uh going through
this uh I guess analyzing these Quantum
bands from here we switch to the
perspective of Wendel Von and Wendel Von
is undergoing his training in the uh
Shield recruitment center he is trying
to demonstrate his ability that he will
be an effective Shield agent and what we
see is that for the most part against
his opponent he's not really able to
demonstrate what's necessary in order to
be effective he's not able to
have that killer instinct as we will
learn later on and this is something
that's brought up to him when he is in
front of Dum Dum Dugan who of course as
we know is the right-hand man of Nick
Fury dum dum Dugan says the problem with
Wendel vaugh is he doesn't have the
Killer Instinct he has Superior fighting
prowess he has a strong intellect but he
just doesn't have what it takes to be a
field agent and so what we see is that
while Wendel vongh hasn't necessarily
failed his shield training that his
assignment will be given to him
somewhere along the line but that he
will not be a field agent from here we
switch to Stark Industries and we see
that Gilbert V among others are
examining the quantum bands and the
quantum bands absorb all forms of energy
that are being uh distributed to them
that there really isn't anything that
can be done to uh to annihilate the
quantum bands more or less from here we
also see that one of the individuals who
is part of this team is going out for I
guess for Refreshments of sorts and what
we see is that this individual is
actually a spy this individual is more
or less informing uh an unknown an
unknown group about the plans that are
going on about how the time to strike
may be relatively close from here we
switch back to Wendel vaugh and W Von's
at home of course he's talking to his
mom and he's sort of going on about how
his position in Shield the fact that
he's not going to be a a field agent
maybe someone that's looked down upon by
his father that he hasn't really made
his dad as proud as he wants him to be
and again this is touching on the
element of Wendel vaugh that tells us
that Wendel vaugh is in such a mindset
that his his underlying drive his
underlying motivation is a desire to
demonstrate to his father that he is
someone that can make his father proud
and this will be an ongoing concept with
regards to his character in
addition what we also see is that the
assignment that's given to Wendel vaugh
is to Simply Safeguard and it's it's
basically an assignment whereby he's to
stand at a door and guard that door and
that door is the access to where his
father is performing his experiment and
this is kind of a let down to Wendel
vaugh this is simply just an instance
whereby he's just going to be monitoring
what it is that his father does and he's
not really going to have any kind of a
Parton it's really for him a way to uh
to feel like a disappointment to his
father from here we see that an
individual named Wes I'm sorry William
Wesley arrives and William Wesley is the
individual that's been brought on board
by Shield to test the quantum bands and
what we see is that William Wesley puts
on the quantum bands and what he does
the quantum bands begin to Surge through
his body with energy now this is quite a
development for uh Gilbert vaugh and his
crew and the reason why is because they
are looking at this idea as maybe some
method they can be used that that they
can be duplicated maybe they can uh add
this into kind of a a super soldier
situation but what we see is that as
William Wesley goes through the process
of using these uh bands the quantum
bands allow him all sorts of energy
projection they allow him the ability to
flight and so on and so forth But as
time progresses it begins to become too
much the energy begins to Surge inside
of him and when it does he finds himself
more or less being overloaded by these
powers and we see that he's totally
disintegrated and this is the same thing
that we had seen with Marvel boy in the
1950s stories uh regarding his
possession of the Marvel bands from here
we see that the individual who is a spy
on behalf of some unknown entity is a
man named Zayn and what we learn here is
that Zayn is a spy for advanced IDE a
mechanics now Advanced idea mechanics is
a technological terrorist group this is
a group that falls in line with Hydra as
both Hydra and aim are led by Baron von
strucker but this is an organization
that exists in terms of employing
cybernetics employing machines in order
to do its bidding what we see here is
that Wendel vaugh and his father are
stuck within the lab and Wendel vaugh is
trying to uh TH or trying to assist in
thoring this aim threat and in the
process he grabs the quantum bands now
when he does he puts them on and his
father says this really isn't a good
idea that there's no telling what'll
happen when he does what we see is that
Wendel vaugh puts on the quintum quantum
bands and when he does he gets a glimpse
of eon from there he transitions back to
the present and we see him wielding the
powers of the quantum bands against uh
aim what we also see here is something
very interesting we see Wendel vaugh
implementing the powers of the quantum
bands in the exact same way that the
Green Lantern implements the power of
his ring in the sense that if William
vaugh I'm sorry if wle vaugh thinks of
something that the ring or I'm sorry the
uh the Bands Will manifest it and so of
course we see that his father tells
Wendel Von to Ram the uh the cyborgs and
when windel Von does the uh the quantum
bands manifest a physical RAM head in
the form of uh energy and of course he's
able to overpower uh the cyborgs and
this is what we see taking place here we
see that Wendel vongh uses his powers in
a multitude of ways to in effect quash
the entire aim uh Invasion by himself
from this point we see that um Wendel
vaugh after the conflict has ended is
approached by uh by Nick Fury and when
he's approached by Nick Fury we see that
he's able to uh control his energy that
we see he's able to allow the energy
that normally would have overloaded him
to kind of disperse and we see that he's
for the most part able to uh totally
control his powers what we also see is
that as a result of him being able to
control his ability and the fact that he
was able to uh to quash the threat that
Nick Fury offers him uh a position now
what we learn here as this uh comic
begins to come to an end is that this
was the backstory this was the initial
story to William I'm sorry um Wendel
vaugh becoming part of the superhero
group that would meet Captain America
and Captain America Issue Number 27 with
that being said I'm going to go ahead
and bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys later
peace we can have no no they have super
scroll oh we don't have super scroll I
thought I thought Marvel had Marvel has
Marvel and fox own the Scrolls but fox
has exclusivity rights for super scroll
which keep it
so you don't like super scroll who cares
he's got the powers of the Fantastic
Four you don't like super scroll what
that's the